president Trump will head to El Paso
Texas tomorrow after the deadly Walmart
shooting there we have now learned the
names of all of those killed in that
attack 22 people are now dead after two
more victims died at the hospital
yesterday at least seven of those killed
are Mexican citizens the city of El Paso
sits at the us-mexico border police say
the alleged gunman posted a racist
manifesto online before the shooting in
it he denounced the growing Hispanic
population in Texas we spoke with one
immigrant who says she feels the
president's language which is echoed in
the manifesto enables violence like this
I think that when you have a president
who says bad things about immigrants
especially from South America and
Central America and Mexico is it just
opens opportunities and it opens doors
to people to do what they want to
and eventually kill the president
denounced white supremacy and racism in
an address yesterday Mexico's government
says it considers the shooting an act of
terror against Mexican citizens
it could take legal action against the
US and may petition to have the shooter
extradited to Mexico